unbelievable let me show you hit that
and a brand new guy brother what's up
fellas
I'm bout to hit some harsh
[Music]
are you doing action what's going on
Mike
it's a pleasure and an honor how you
doing good feeling good that's right I'm
in Brooklyn right now I'm on I can't
tell the street but you know I'm over
here in a little movie about a park okay
you know I'm over here right by the BQE
by like Meeker you know just getting
Hyde so now you know it's the best time
I'm over here about to work out in a
minute I mean I would love that
don't be amazing I mean I had a lot of
plans before this dumb [ __ ] but I'm
still I'm still going according to plan
life is what it is man you know you got
to take all the [ __ ] that comes with it
right now I'm just making sure all the
family's good you know doing all the
food shopping for the mom you know
cooking every day say again yeah
something coming up only for dolphins
new album new project well they're
dropping out I'm I'm hoping within the
next month or so I'm gonna be dropping
music very soon I got all kinds of stuff
coming actually they're about my last my
show [ __ ] that's delicious has been held
hostage for a minute yeah
yeah yeah it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful [ __ ] thing you know what I
mean
it's one of my it's one of my one of my
favorite things I've ever done in life
I did
what's he was he a blower on is he
alright of course standing on his head
thank you trying to come home they told
me trying to come on I mean they should
just let him come home this virus got
everybody should you should just let him
out I know that for sure
my man Tom Hardy played him in the movie
was a good I like that movie you seen
the other movie with him when he played
both the brothers the Kray brothers the
Kray twins
Wendy Kray
yeah you can write each other that's
amazing
what do you have to say anything good
inspiration a young man anything
speaking of that the Irishman you know
was amazing I wiped it quite a few times
yeah you enjoyed it yeah you know a lot
of people gave you some criticism you're
not saying that it wasn't his finest
work but in my opinion I thought it was
one of the top top pieces of art he's
produced it's a beautiful project thank
you
exactly exactly you get it you get it
yeah I know you do
and he did too at the end to the end he
got anybody no no that's right
doesn't even matter dying alone
subsetting I mean you could you could
say a lot without saying anything I grew
up in Queens man in Flushing Queens and
hip-hop and rap was my life buying tape
set at Queens Center Mall you know going
to Green Acres mall and buying tapes and
just being fully entrenched wearing
caulk and not [ __ ] you know all our
friends everyone dancing we have a very
ethnically diverse group of friends when
I was young you know what I mean
so and you know in Flushing is like
every type of human being on earth
stacked up oh yeah yeah there's some guy
got there's a guy in Greenpoint they got
some good pigeons he has some beauties
yeah I mean listen he told me he could
make some real money when he races and
it's talking about three you know six
figures listen I think I think I think
the pride of four million bucks
unbelievable I actually enjoy South
Africa I was down there was a beautiful
thing I know you're right
I enjoy I enjoyed your Hannah's burg I
enjoy it I've only been South Africa and
Morocco yeah I need to I need to do this
Central Park listen oh there's a lot of
beautiful people there's a lot of
beautiful things to see all over the
world of course I love traveling
it's one of my favorite things I love to
get high I love to travel I love to eat
and right now I'm loving to work out
yeah I got my push-up game back I got my
push-up game back right now straight
right now I'm gonna tell you why I you
know usually I would do about right now
I could do 30 straight I used when I was
really working out hard I was able to
pop 100 easy but I was on a little bit
of juice I was much lighter than I am
now you know right now I'm [ __ ] 326 I
was 363 about two months ago got on the
[ __ ] scam I could around nine months
ago seventy pound it just you have to do
him I couldn't believe my selves like
what the hell is going on so I just went
in I've been cooking for myself feeling
good
stem cell me with that of course you
actually had it I did yesterday where
did you go you had it right there oh you
had you had the the plasma replacement
[Music]
that's crazy
I had that I had the plasma replacement
done on my knee I feel like a million
bucks right now does I know nothing
there's no downs our debt I mean we're
both we're both living Testaments of
that
and what do you think about alternative
okay excuse me
ticket alternative medicine
I mean alternative medicine is how I
live life I don't take any other I'll
take [ __ ] I don't sake like any
pharmaceutical stuff and you
over-the-counter stuff straight up see I
have I haven't done I ask of my my
partner my beautiful my beautiful wife
to be has done ayahuasca in coca-cola in
Colombia in like the end of the world
Accord of fin del mundo mushrooms
mushrooms we get it all over there
that's what I want to do I want to do
the total I want to do the toe what I
want to do all kinds of stuff I want to
do peyote oh yeah I want to do peyote -
I got a dupe we should do peyote
together we're at that point mean I'm at
that point in my life right I'd like to
see nothing but beauty I like to I like
to see what else is out there two years
it's unbelievable hit that and a Branson
guy what's up so this then may connect
examine what kind of spices yeah you
should all you should always have a wood
plank with cedar plank so you could
roast it on the cedar plank you can put
some lemon a little bit of salt and
pepper some beautiful olive oil in a
bowl mix it around you can even hit it
with a touch of honey not yet so you get
kind of a glaze
is on their roasts that [ __ ] I'm gonna
take notes thanks action welcome I'm
about to hit some hash yes I'm starving
with some some pure straight from Denver
it's called modified mince see I need to
be there with you I'm there with you I
feel you right now I'm there with you no
yeah that's real we're um yeah I mean I
don't you obviously some millions of
people in this world you're an idol and
I'm one of those you know what I mean
growing up in New York City watching
fights with my grandfather my Albanian
grandfather yeah you know the main
ticket you're the main event here's a
guy for real immigrants shipment made
some some octopus last night yeah you
know that's one of the most you know
that's an ancient creature I feel like I
like when you smoked DMT or when you do
some sort of psychedelic you should pair
it with an ancient creature you know
what I mean so I smoked DMT and I'll eat
the octopus and I'll gather all the
knowledge that I really need for about
50 lifetimes you always wanted to know
what
looks really they use this is so many
paintings it doesn't even have blood I
feel like the ancient purpose of the
octopus was B it was like the main the
main mother [ __ ] like it was the driver
you know like it was the captain of that
[ __ ] when he was we see how he had so
many tentacles they have all this reach
they you know they just have all these
things going on they can reach so many
different people at a time so they were
the coordinators of everything and they
led you know that's why they could
disguise themselves with camouflage
through electrical you know pulses and
yeah well yeah this tales there's tales
of the sea with Krakens and all kinds of
large well in you know Humboldt squid
could be I don't even know like I'm but
like the size of a [ __ ] boat like a
massive boat totally attacking a boat
that's what I mean those are those
Humboldt squid they call them the red
devil you know those [ __ ] are
crazy they attack everything they're in
the Sea of Cortez in Mexico they're in
there in Humboldt up in you know in
California that's where they're from
they're all loving down that area scary
[ __ ] man yeah that's why it's
like a ritual when I eat it you know we
ain't alone and I they had that that
beak exactly that was one big you know
that because made of your nickname I
need ya behind ya
it's made of metal it's miss it's
actually it's a substance stronger than
chatline it can by 2 I and by to Jeff
lon
it could devour it Bernie they've seen
they've seen things in the sea where
swordfish massive swordfish massive tuna
just stripped meat off the bone like
some cartoon [ __ ] by Humboldt squid and
big [ __ ] Red Devils this is
great they can I don't know man I don't
know
my friends we love rap and he was
rapping and my friend mayhem the rent my
best friend he was rapping he was like
yo rap and I just started rapping also
and that's really how it happened and
that's and here we are 10 years later
before that I was a four was a chef I
know it's really it's not it's not
intentional but it's just all these
things I'm into I'm just I guess I'm
like that out to push I just I have
reached up so many different things you
know you like dome anything until you're
calm like the octopus like the teacher
you always call me never excited only
when you throw it if it ain't the blind
people that's right changing this color
to get the hell out of here pulsating
both you know listen I'm a calm guy but
I love visit no chameleon - I forgot II
camouflage the comfort the chameleon
amazing animal it's it's a rare animal
you know
it's like one is it's it's one of those
it's one of those freaks of nature one
of those one of those unspeak
unthinkable things I had it had it how
was this even created you know the
mechanics exactly has no idea the
mechanics behind that it's unbelievable
you could write chairs on it's very true
yeah we're just a bag of flesh for our
soul you know it's just our souls flow
through different pieces of flesh and
we're just this machine that we are
right now when this is done it's like
when you play Nintendo you just press
that reset button you back in the game
you - Mike you - man
much love I can't wait to come out there
I mean it would be a pleasure you too
man be safe out here right thank you